stranger things Star Wars Westworld
queer I Riverdale I'm not just naming
thanks I have brand new info about all
of them hey everyone I'm ash cross and
any direct Oh couldn't be here today
because well hey Danny its ash are you
on your way in already yeah go ahead and
turn around there's been like an
electrical fire so we're we're shut down
for the day the elevators aren't working
the carpark is full just been one of
those bizarre la floods you know
everyone is sick there's no more coffee
yeah you know what you've been working
so hard I just want you to rest sleep
sleep sleep for the day bye I'm not sure
why but I am taking over the show and
we're gonna get strange and by that I
mean stranger things season 3 details
but first of course we're gonna talk
about Star Wars solo a Star Wars story
is the next Star Wars movie starring
Alden Ehrenreich as Han Solo and Donald
Glover as Lando Calrissian I know we
know these characters we've seen them
before but we don't know much about the
new kids from Hans past including West
world's Tandy Newton
we only got a small glimpse of her in
the trailer but Tandy told et's Bryce
sander that an image is worth a thousand
parsecs that literally means nothing
parsecs our unit of distance you look so
badass in the solo trailer oh haha what
can you tell me about your character and
solo um if I think that the clip that
you see even though it's really brief
tells you a lot okay you know there she
is holding what looks like a weapon and
in a state of natural empowerment you
know both the way she looks and her
attitude and I loved
I'm not playing a character I loved the
tea that we started with and then the
team that we went on to have with Ron
Howard I loved all the directors that we
have in the movie and it was a privilege
and I just adored working with Woody
Harrelson I just had so much fun you can
definitely feel that attitude right and
that literal one second we see of her
which is a testament to Tandy's acting
chops but my biggest takeaway here is
her comment about Woody Harrelson she
said it was great working with him which
means they're probably gonna be spending
a significant amount of time together
he's playing a new character named
Tobias Beckett who is supposedly a sort
of early mentor for Hahn but
Tandy didn't mention the other cast
members so I really hope we don't lose
her early I mean I don't think everyone
will die in this movie like rogue one or
anything but I do think there's gonna be
a couple of losses time will tell but
not that much time because this movie is
out May 25th and that is real soon of
course before heading to a galaxy far
far away she's heading back to the wild
wild west you like that line for
Westworld season two we have so many
interviews up right now including James
Marsden talking about his but yeah Evan
Rachel Wood and even more from tandy so
Wes world fans check those out after
this video but as promised we're gonna
get strange it might feel too soon to
talk about stranger things season 3 but
it isn't justice for barb justice for
Bob stranger things closed down
PaleyFest which is a full festival for
the best of TV and our TV expertly and
Aguilera went into the upside down to
meet up with our favorite tune here
again barb oh my gosh oh okay because I
have some news season three goes back
into production next month and even
though they're keeping all those secrets
locked up in Hawkins lab executive
producer Shawn Levy gave us a little
something check it out if ET we need to
know I know you need to know and you
know I need to not tell I will say that
we start shooting next month and getting
a one-year time jump we're getting one
year time jump to summer of 85 and it's
it's a season about change
it's about evil changes relationships
change some dynamics that you
you know are revealed to be a little
different than you might have assumed
some involving this burly gentleman to
my right chief hopper but yeah I really
have to stay that bag I'm so sorry I
know that things are gonna get darker
they always do what are the chances that
we could get some romance in season
three high probability of romance that
by the way just became the quote that
will be used season three high
probability of romance on several fronts
don't say that to anyone else yeah
hashtag chopper hashtag jump their
endgame right really our endgame and I
also want some more Mike in 11 they had
the best kind of sure you really do but
speaking of 11 million looked absolutely
stunning Wow night
it look at that dress my goodness it was
really sweet she told me she's so
excited to get back to production so
that she can work with the kids cuz she
was just filming the latest Godzilla
movie it was just all adults for so long
and she missed her stranger fam she's
going back home to Netflix and you no
one else is coming back to my Flex what
yes
queer I season two yes honey yes yes yes
yes it was just announced that the Fab
five is coming back but it better not be
eight episodes they better make 48
million thousand hundred episodes can
you believe that's a good episode order
right it's really really major really
really major gave us permission and you
all love TV gossip I have juicy secrets
straight from the Riverdale cast
including information from Madeline
patch about what happened to Cheryl so
tune in to this week Sweetwater secrets
on Wednesday and Thursday for all that
gossip oh gosh thank you so much for
that easily and and thank you guys so
much for watching
dennee is back tomorrow but in the
meantime let me know your thoughts and
feelings about Tandy Newton and Sola who
do you think she is do you think she'll
make it out alive I'm always available
to talk on Twitter but for now I'm
heading to the upside down aka happy
hour on a Monday
[Music]